we have much more of our interview with
our Kelly addressing his current
relationship with two young women 23
year-old Joycelyn Savage and 21 year old
Ezreal Clary lived with him at his
Chicago home their parents believe that
the 52 year old R&B singer has
brainwashed their daughters the Clarys
attorney released a statement calling
Kelly a liar manipulator and sociopath
later this morning savages parents plan
to hold a news conference addressing our
interview but here's what Kelly told us
about the two young women what is your
relationship with them I love them and
it's almost it's like they're my
girlfriend's it's like you know we have
a relationship it's real and I know guys
like I've known as all my life to have
five or six women okay so don't go to
help me okay because that's the truth
the fact that they're much younger than
you I don't look at much younger than me
I just look at legal I just look at you
you I mean now I don't know if you're
married I don't know I don't know a
relationship I don't know what you you
know I don't know but one might be older
than the other one might be younger than
the other okay so I just look at legal
okay
people there are old and me and it like
younger women is that younger women
they're like older me are you a older
man that likes younger women I'm a older
man to love all women okay Kelly says he
met Joycelyn savage after her father
brought her to one of his concerts when
she was 19 I didn't go looking for a job
in savage I was doing my show he brought
her an axe a friend of mine to put her
on the stage with our Kelly make sure
she's on the stage as real Clary also
met Kelly at one of his concerts her
parents say Kelly pulled the then 17
year-old on stage back in 2015 they say
they had hoped that she would become
Kelly's musical protege as real Clary
what can you tell what is your
relationship with her right now
I'm seeing her you were seeing her she's
21 I'm seeing her she's 21
yeah but did you start seeing her at 17
solutely not did you have sex with her
she was 70 absolutely not absolutely not
although her parents wanted me to know
her last thing they have text messages
that show that you had sex with her 2017
claim so you're saying you did not have
sex with absolutely not you are with two
women right now you love them they say
they love you what kind of love is it
that keeps these these young women away
from their families their families are
zombies I'm talking right now about
joseline because you know who's gonna
answer your question what kind of father
what kind of mother will sell their
daughter to a man who did that how come
it was okay for me to see them until
they wouldn't get no money from it why
would you take your daughter if I was
gonna take my daughter and she's 19
years old to a 49 year old icon whatever
celebrity or our Kelly concert or
whoever it is I'm not gonna put on the
stage and leave her what take it to the
concert their father is more into my
music and know about my music than they
do
you're saying the the parents handed
their daughters as well and joseline
over to you is that what you're saying
to us absolutely absolutely I know you
jesting that that that the parents sold
the daughters to him he is saying that
the parents are in it for the money is
what he's saying he is saying that the
boat that both sets of parents brought
the daughters to him in hopes that they
would work together and that the parents
could do a deal with them that maybe the
daughters could work I mean he tells a
very different story I talked to as
Arella father the night before the
interview he very much believes that his
daughter's been brainwashed he says his
daughter loves to sing and that's how
she got involved with our Kelly he says
he has text messages that proved they
had sex when she was 17 and he so you
know there's all sorts of court cases
going on
it really is Nora I have just to have to
say a hot mess all the way around on all
sides on also
and Jocelyn's parents as we mentioned
are going to be holding a press
conference yes they are holding a press
conference later Jay will be interesting
to hear what they have to say